Does gun control actually
stop gun violence?
So first, let's point
out a quick statistic.
Violence statistics-- not
just gun violence statistics,
violence statistics matter.
It is true that if have an
armed population, in many cases
you have a more
polite population.
According to PolitiFact,
which is a far-left source,
for England and Wales,
the rate of violent crimes
is 775 per 100,000 people.
For the United States, that
rate is 383 violent crimes
per 100,000 people.
The UK has double the violent
crime rate of the United States
according to PolitiFact.
And they have virtually
no guns in their society.
How about gun control
in other nations?
What you would expect is, again,
this one to one correlation.
Because people keep
suggesting over, and over,
and over, more guns
means more crime.
OK.
Let's look at the
European countries.
Let's take the United
States completely out of it.
OK.
The gun homicide rate in the
United States, first of all,
has declined faster
than Australia's did it
after its gun buyback
and ban program.
And it's hard to
measure the impact
on mass shootings of
Australia's gun buyback program,
because there were so few
mass shootings before that.
But if you look at gun
control in other nations,
right, the Small
Arms Survey of 2007
estimates civilian ownership
of firearms by nation.
The United States ranked
by far at the top.
We have 101 guns
per 100 residents.
Number eight is
Norway and Norway
has 31 guns per 100 residents.
France is ninth.
The UK ranks 82nd.
So the UK doesn't have
virtually any guns.
Norway has a lot more guns.
And yet Norway is
near the bottom
of the list in terms
of homicide rate,
just 0.56 murders per
100,000 inhabitants.
In France ranks somewhere
near the middle of the pack.
They have triple the
homicide rate of Norway,
but they have way fewer guns.
Which suggests that maybe this
has very little to do with guns
and it has a lot more to
do with the population that
is in your country.
And you see this in
the United States too.
There's no
correlation whatsoever
between a state having
a high firearm ownership
rate and a high crime rate.
So the 10 lowest
homicide jurisdictions
in the United States are New
Hampshire, Vermont, Iowa,
Massachusetts, Utah,
Minnesota, Maine, Hawaii,
Idaho, and Wyoming.
Six of those 10 states
earn a D or an F
from the Brady Campaign
on gun control.
I mean, if you go to
Vermont or New Hampshire,
everybody has a gun and
there's no gun violence.
And the reason for that
is because the people
in Vermont and New Hampshire
are not shooting each other.
And this is really not
all that difficult.
And when you look at the
other end of the spectrum,
when you look at the states
that do have high rates of gun
violence, there are a
bunch of states, actually,
they have a lot of gun control.
And, of course, everybody in
the Second Amendment community
is familiar with localities like
Washington D.C. and Chicago.